[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
sergei d'art c'est le gouverneur de la
région de lougansk dans l'est de
l'ukraine il est avec nous depuis un
lieu tenu secret pour des raisons de
sécurité merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
bonjour alors la contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans la région voisine de
kharkiv qui a surpris le monde entier
marque-t-elle d'après vous un tournant
dans cette guerre
certainement
tout ce qui s'était passé dans la région
de kharkiv a prouvé encore une fois la
capacité
de l'armée eux craignent non seulement
se défendre mais aussi
passer à la contre offensive et donc
battre l'armée russe non seulement dans
une ville mais dans des grandes régions
alors est-ce que la retraite des troupes
russes dans des conditions semble-t-il
quand même assez chaotique est ce que ça
donne ça ne vous a quand même pas
surpris
milliards ou les mines yahoo ce qui m'a
étonné non c'est pas la leur retraite
qui m'a étonné c'est leur rapidité de
cette robe de ce retrait si on analyse
toutes les campagnes
de russie on peut dire que la russie n'a
jamais fait la guerre un adversaire très
fort donc sur le champ de bataille sont
très faibles alors évidemment la
question qui se pose maintenant
c'est votre région la région de lougansk
est ce que désormais la contre offensive
va se concentrer sur l'ouganda et plus
globalement sur le dôme basse
à ce qu'ajoute à
lougansk aux bleus expliqué comme ça
donc la région de lougansk une partie de
la région de donetsk
bien évidemment on va continuer la d
occupation y aura une contre offensive
mais ce n'est c'est pas sûr que ce
serait en premier lieu pour le président
et pour l'état major de militaires de
l'ukraine
la vie de chaque soldat est important
donc l'opération sera préparée d'une
façon très détaillée et pour l'instant
nous ne pouvons pas en parler beaucoup
alors et est ce que dans dans cette
région où il ya eu des batailles très
sévère en ce soin de licences
severodonetsk est-ce que vous avez aussi
vu des troupes russes partir de
certaines localités parce que l on vu ce
qui s'était passé dans la région de rare
qu'yves et peut-être sont-elles inquiète
ni être patriote pour l'instant non
pour l'instant les troupes qui ont se
sont ensuite la région de quartier et
ils essaient de s'enterrer dans notre
région pour construire des bastions
alors justement est ce que vous craignez
que la résistance que les russes n'ont
peut-être pas opposés dans la région de
kharkiv ce soit chez vous dans la région
de lougansk qu'elle se manifeste et que
là on est véritablement à nouveau des
batailles extrêmement rude et qui touche
les civils notamment
gagné chez nous bien sûr
nous sommes très inquiet pour les civils
les cinq mois qui se sont écoulés on a
cherché à évacuer le maximum de gens d
des territoires où il y avait des
combats on a évacué plus de 300 mille
civils malheureusement les civils
meurent dans la guerre pendant la guerre
cissé il ya des combats rudes nous nous
inviterons la population à rester dans
les abris est ce que dans votre région
évidemment on a beaucoup parlé en tout
cas
en occident de boudhha de borodianka
avec ses crimes de guerre supposés
russes qui ont été découverts est ce que
chez vous aussi dans votre région vous
avez découvert des charniers des
attaques délibérées contre des cibles
civiles
as many plus tout plein et un voyage
merci je crie ma principale de la russie
on l'est on en saura une fois que nos
régions seront libérés l'ukraine sera
libérée mais il ya déjà des exemples de
du comportement barbare nous savons très
bien que dans les noeuds c'est pas dans
les handicaps et les haies les retraités
qui ont aidé
[Musique]
cinquantaine de personnes ont été tuées
de cette façon nous savons très bien que
les colonnes de réfugiés qui cherchait à
s'évacuer ont été aussi fusillé on leur
a tiré dessus c'est 80 personnes ont été
tuées mais les charniers les plus graves
seront découvrir après la libération de
la région alors on sait que dans cette
région aussi à dos nièce et dans
d'autres endroits très récemment la
russie a annoncé qu'elle voulait tenir
des référendums d'autodétermination est
ce que vous pensez que en raison de la
contre offensive
dorénavant ce projet est totalement
irréaliste
aouja
oui bien sûr déjà les occupants disent
que et vont ils veulent reporter la date
du référendum qui était prévu pour qu'on
septembre un temps indéterminé
alors évidemment dans cette contre
offensive
il y à la stratégie définie par le
commandement militaire ukrainien mais il
ya aussi les armes occidentales les
occidentaux disent toutefois qu'ils ne
veulent pas livré à l'ukraine des
missiles à longue portée parce que ils
craignent que ils seront utilisés pour
frapper directement le territoire russe
est ce que vous le regrettez est-ce que
vous pensez que ce serait une arme
importante peut-être pas pour l'utiliser
mais en tout cas pour
porter le défi face aux russes
à 19
sur certainement bien savoureusement
césar ces armements pour aider à
détruire les entrepôts qui se trouvent
dans les arrières russe sur le
territoire russe et le peuple ukrainien
est le nôtre commandement et le
président sont des gens très raisonnable
et nous cherchons pas
aller dans les territoires
de nos voisins et tirer sur les villes
même si c'était si c'est des villes du
pays qui est agresseurs alors est-ce que
vous pensez que dans un délai peut-être
d'ici quelques semaines si quelques mois
la région de lougansk votre région peut
revenir sous le contrôle une craignant y
compris la partie de la région qui est
occupé depuis plusieurs années par la
russie est ce que dorénavant vous pensez
qu'on est proche tout ça
sans aucun doute
c'est l'objectif de tout le peuple
ukrainien c'est l'objectif du président
le président l'a dit plusieurs fois ci
nous devons
occuper tout le territoire de la région
de lougansk
quelle que soit la date de l'occupation
24 février où depuis 2014 alors beaucoup
craignent que suite à leur retraite les
russes
se venge un petit peu on a vu des
frappes sur les infrastructures
dans la région de de kharkiv est est ce
que vous craignez cela que les russes
peut-être parce que la situation ne va
pas comme il le souhaite sur le terrain
se venge entre guillemets sur les
populations civiles dans votre région
ce qui se passe déjà il
trace les barrages sur les fleuves et
ils cassent les centrales thermiques
maintenant ils ont bombardé maintenant
aujourd'hui jean bombardé la ville de
kouqian à les civils ont été blessés il
ils ont ils essaient de casser
l'infrastructure
d'un pays terroristes comme la russie on
peut s'attendre à tout alors est ce que
vous redoutez aussi peut-être des
tentatives d'assassinats ciblés contre
des dirigeants comme vous au niveau
local voire au niveau national comme le
président est ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous prenez en compte ou est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est une menace un
petit peu exagéré
c'est pas du tout exagéré ses teintes
une menace très réelle et donc on
cherche à être très prudents
et on cherche à garder le secret de nos
déplacements toujours et est ce que vous
imaginez que le président hélène ski on
l'a vu récemment à idiome dans la région
de harkis qui a été libéré est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il viendra bientôt dans
la région de lougansk pour les mêmes
raisons
signature à 4 bien sûr je sais mon
souhait le plus ardent pour moi
j'aimerais bien moi même visité localité
libérée et je rencontrerai avec plaisir
notre président quel que soit l'endroit
où il arriverait série haidar gouverneur
de la région de lougansk dans l'est de
l'ukraine je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir répondu aux questions de france
et merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]